hi there steve kaufman here
uh today i'm going to talk about
polyglottary and
multilingualism
polyglottary is a term that i became
aware of only fairly recently it's a
term coined i think by doctor or by
professor alex argelis
and
he has
dedicated his life to learning languages
and he's learned quite a range of
languages
probably languages in all the different
language families and modern languages
ancient languages and he has a very
disciplined approach to language
learning and has a lot of experience and
it's his idea to set up an institute
where he would teach people how to learn
multiple languages how to become
polyglots and it's his idea to invite
a number of accomplished polyglots to
work with him
and to share their own experiences and
he he in fact invites people with
different
approaches to language learning to share
their experience
which i think is a very good idea
because
there are a lot of polyglots i call them
linguists people who speak a lot of
languages
uh
on the internet for example but not only
on the internet there's a number of them
everywhere
but the ones that we can listen to on
youtube
they have a number of things
approaches and opinions on how to learn
etc which they share which which are
common to them but they all have things
that they do differently and so to have
these polyglots come in and
you know expose potential language
learnings to language learners to
different approaches i think is a very
good thing because if these proficient
polyglots can have different approaches
that would suggest that that learners
would benefit from at least
looking at different possible approaches
and then deciding which one works best
for them
uh i must say that in my own experience
you know i never really approached
language learning as sort of trying to
learn as many languages as i could or or
even you know
prior to say
the most recent 10 years i would learn a
language that i needed to learn because
i was there i needed to learn french
when i was studying in france
uh i was sent to hong kong to learn
chinese i lived in japan i got
interested in german we were doing
business in germany
spanish swedish it was always
a specific interest in a specific
language without necessarily thinking
when i finish this language then i'll do
another language whereas today i i must
admit that i'm my mood now is that
if i if i get to a
sufficient level in my check
then i'm going to do another language i
don't know whether i will you know stay
in the slavic area and go on to do
polish or whether i'll go off into the
middle east and do turkish or farsi or
arabic
uh but i definitely want to learn
another language so you know i've been
bitten by the polyglot bug
uh however you know in all of this
what strikes me is there are lots of
these keener polyglots i don't know if
there are more
today than in previous times but i think
we are more aware of them because of
youtube and the internet
uh for example at link i'm amazed to see
the number of people on our site who
study multiple languages three four five
six eight languages that they're
studying at the same time
and i always thought that people would
come on to study one language somebody
wanted to learn spanish would come on
and learn spanish or people who were
needed to improve their english or the
french or the russian or the chinese but
actually people are studying five six
languages so i think this is an
interesting trend
um typically in school we have one maybe
two languages
and typically in north america it's one
language in europe it might be two but
it would be two european languages but
what we're now seeing via the internet
and elsewhere is that people are
studying asian languages african
languages middle eastern languages
people are really getting into this
whole polyglot
uh field of activity and so i think in
that sense professor argelia's
initiative could be a very interesting
one because i think there are a lot of
people who would like to learn multiple
languages and
all i am sure all the polyglots will
tell you that with each
uh
you know successive language it gets
easier to learn plus you can group them
you know if i do russian i can do check
and then i can do polish
and certainly the chinese helps because
of the vocabulary with your japanese and
then you can take your chinese and
japanese that'll help you with your
korean
so you can start knocking off some of
these languages and build up your uh
real build up your resume if you're so
inclined
but
with all of that though i still come
back to the fact that a majority of
people particularly in the
english-speaking world
only speak one language and of course
that's because english is such a
dominant international language which is
a good thing i sometimes see people
knocking english when i see
you know
people from foreign countries
foreign cultures
uh communicating with each other
so well in english i realized what a
tremendously
useful and practical tool
worldwide english is
but
it does make it easy for english
speakers to be lazy
and yet i constantly come across people
say even here in vancouver when i tell
them that i have this website for
language like oh i'm really interested
i've always wanted to learn spanish i
always wanted to learn chinese or french
so at that level these people are very
interested uh
and many of them go take courses
but how many of them really follow
through
and so so it's one thing to you know
professor argelis is going to help
people have five languages and move it
up to ten
but
how do we get the people who only speak
one language and it's not just english
speakers let's be fair i was at a at a
charity concert the other evening
you know
on behalf of the victims
of the tsunami in japan who are still
dealing with lots and lots of problems
and the majority of people at this
charity concert were people from the
japanese community here in vancouver and
particularly first generation immigrants
people who have been living here for 20
30 years and i was quite astounded by
how poor the average level of english
was amongst these people
and so i'm always
you know i come back to this point how
do you help people learn that first
foreign language well because that's the
biggest step what can we do can we
spread the word can we
you know convince people that that they
need to spend the time the need to get
motivated to learn the language they
don't need to get hung up on the grammar
up front uh again this you know this
russian fellow at the university of
dalana saying you know if you want to
learn language go out and buy a book on
linguistics most people aren't going to
do that most people are i still believe
somewhat intimidated by all these rules
upfront and frustrated that they can't
remember them and frustrated that they
can't produce the language effectively
and and it's my belief as many of you
who have seen me here before
will know that if you can get people to
relax enjoy the language find a way to
enjoy the language enjoy the songs enjoy
the tv programs read listen don't worry
about speaking until you want to or have
an opportunity to can we make that first
language easier can we somehow encourage
people to expose themselves to more of
the language but in a way where they
actually start to notice like i was
quite impressed by these
many of these japanese canadians been
here 20 30 years
who still use japanese sentence
or word order
and and and yet and yet you'll see young
people who come here from japan
on a working holiday and they work in uh
in a restaurant where they're serving
uh you know canadians uh
and they're speaking english all the
time and their their attitude they're
they're fun they want to be with it they
want to be part of the community and
those people learn to speak very quickly
so
you know i don't know
really how we get this sense of just
have fun with the language
out to more people so that
we can genuinely get more people
speaking more than one language because
if they get the first one down then they
can get the second one and from then on
you know it's not a big big step to
becoming a polyglot
but you first have to get that first
language down so i'd be interested in
knowing what people out there think can
be done to help the many many people who
struggle with learning that first
foreign language once we do that we can
move on to polyglottery thank you for
listening